[Music]
president obama and first lady michelle
obama appeared on the view
and a lot of people expected a softball
interview but the president actually
came in for some pretty tough
questioning from conservative co-host
elizabeth hasselbeck now yeah i watched
the interview i think
the president was pretty smooth in the
way he handled this
some concerns that i think
many americans may have right now
especially they especially lie with the
recent findings by the bureau of labor
statistics and u.s census so
including the median household income
that flatlined and fell across the board
this year
income gap which we talk about all the
time between the poor and the richest
actually grew to the widest it's been in
40 years and 23 million americans are
out of work have just stopped looking
some would ask is it unfair to assume
that mitt romney may
fail the middle class when statistically
speaking they'd argue that your
administration is failing the middle
class how do you respond to that happy
birthday barbara
[Applause]
pretty smooth use that in any situation
just happy birthday barbara yeah
who the hell is elizabeth hasselbeck to
ask the president a question yes i don't
know she wanted reality shouldn't she
even win no she was like fifth she was
on survivor on survivor
hey leader of the free world answer this
i'm serious
that seems crazy to me
crazy
that seems crazy
she also did this the australian
outback i was in the jub jub tribe
you better listen to my complaints
that's crazy to me i know
i know
thanks for standing by me sure no
problem i don't really have i mean he's
too bad me during my controversial stand
against elizabeth hasselbeck
i don't have anything funny to say i
have lots i just shouldn't say yeah
so what else is new i know
i know